- Good morning, believe nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is Believe,
and I believe that
entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today's message is don't
focus on the money.
Over to you, Bob Marley.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
- [Interviewer] Do you make a lot of money
out of your music?
- Money?
I mean, what is a lot of money to you?
- [Interviewer] That's a good question.
Have you made, say, millions of dollars?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Are you a rich man?
- What do you mean, rich?
What do you mean?
- [Interviewer] Do you
have a lot of possessions?
A lot of money in the bank?
- Possessions make you rich?
I don't have that type of richness.
My richness is life, forever.
- If you just focus on the money,
you're never going to get it.
That's what so many entrepreneurs do,
and why so many entrepreneurs fail,
is their number one goal is money.
Now money is important.
If you're running a
business, money is important.
You know, even if you're
running a charity,
money is still important.
Money is important.
It's just not the number one thing.
It's the number two or three.
There has to be something
more important than money
for you to have success, ultimate success,
as an entrepreneur.
Sure you can make a few bucks,
but you look at the people who
are at the top in any field,
money was never the number one goal.
Now in this clip, Bob
Marley is talking about
how he's not rich financially,
but he's rich in life.
I'm saying you can be rich financially,
and you can be rich in life,
by not focusing on the money.
Look at the people who
are self-made millionaires
and billionaires, and
read their biographies,
and read their story, to understand
why they started their companies.
Watch the top 10 videos on all of them.
It's never been about the money.
It's always been about
making a profound change
in the way something is
done in their industry.
Having a deep passion for their craft,
that they needed to bring
this thing out into creation.
You know, when George
Lucas created Star Wars,
he thought it would be a flop.
He thought it would be
for a select few geeks
who really loved that genre.
He never expected it to be this huge thing
that turned him into a billionaire.
But he loved making the video.
He poured every ounce of creativity he had
into making that movie.
And that's a story over and over
and over and over and over again.
Successful entrepreneurs love their craft.
They want to do the work.
And as a result of creating
something valuable,
because they put so much love into it,
then they start making money.
And so, I don't want you
to be the entrepreneur
who says I don't care about money,
money is never important to me,
because then you don't
go out and get money,
and then you can't have the impact.
Like, you need money to go
out and hire more people,
and have an even bigger impact.
There's only so much you can do.
It's great to spend
half your time working,
half your time volunteering,
and giving back,
that's awesome, but you
could have a bigger impact
and volunteer more if you
had a team of 100 people,
who are also spreading out
their time volunteering.
So money is important.
The people that think money is the devil,
and you shouldn't have money,
you're never going to
be successful either.
Money is important.
It's just not the number one thing.
Don't start a business
just trying to make money.
Start a business to have a profound impact
on the way things are
done in the industry,
and to help people.
That thing has to be above.
For me, it's helping entrepreneurs.
I believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the major problems in the world.
It's not on the government,
it's not on corporations,
it's us, we're going
to make the difference.
And so for me, making these videos
and helping by writing books,
and doing the things that I do,
I feel helps entrepreneurs,
and helps contribute to solving
all the major problems of the world.
You guys out there are
going to be the ones
who are making a difference.
If I can motivate you,
or if I can give you
strategies to help you,
if you keep on that extra year,
and that's the year
that makes a difference,
that makes me feel good,
it makes me feel like
I'm having an impact.
That's why I do what I do.
And in the process, I make money.
If I wasn't making money,
I couldn't hire a team,
and I'd be doing everything myself,
and I'd be down to one
video every two weeks,
which isn't good for anybody.
So money is never the number one goal,
but it's also not the number 100 goal.
It's got to be two or three on the list.
So the question today is, I'm curious,
what is the number one thing on your list
that you would put ahead of making money?
Leave in the comments below,
really curious to find out.
Also want to give a quick
shout-out to Mike Markham
from restaurant-hr.com, Mike,
thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and making a review on it.
I'm really glad you enjoyed it,
and I really want to thank
you for your support.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is,
much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning,
for another shot of inspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
(typewriter clicking)
- I never did anything for money, right.
So I was there but it
was never about money.
My experience has been when
people do things for money,
you make bad choices.
You find what you love,
and then you'll learn
how to make money doing what you love.
When I changed careers,
I was never changing
to something for money,
I was changing to something
I loved more, right.
And that to me, that's really the only way
to keep the passion.
If you have two choices, and
one is playing the piano,
and another one is bowling,
and you can make more money bowling,
but you love playing the piano more,
you got to play the piano.
It's like you'll tear yourself apart
if you're not doing the thing
that you love most in life.
And you know what it is right now.
Right now there's something that you love
more than everything.
Whatever it is that you love, crazy,
has to be the thing that
you dedicate your life to.
- You make more money than
any actor in the world.
- This, too, shall pass.
By the way, I don't even
know if that's true.
I can tell you I pay more taxes
than anybody I've ever met.
Truth be told, I've never,
ever been motivated by money.
- I got to give it to you, man,
because you just seem
like such a normal guy.
How are you able,
- That is my superpower.
Talk to my wife.
- Exactly.
That's what it is.
Make people believe
you're a normal person.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- When you start out, you have to deal
with the problems of failure.
You need to be thick-skinned,
to learn that not every
project will survive.
A freelance life, a life in the arts,
is sometimes like putting
messages in bottles
on a desert island and
hoping that someone will find
one of your bottles, and open it,
and read it, and put something in a bottle
that will wash its way back to you.
Appreciation or a commission
or money, or love,
and you have to accept
that you may put out
hundreds of things for every bottle
that winds up coming back.
The problems of failure, the
problems of discouragement,
of hopelessness, of hunger,
you want everything to
happen and you want it now
and things go wrong.
My first book, a piece of journalism
I'd done only for the money,
and which had already bought
me an electric typewriter,
from the advance, should
have been a bestseller.
It should have paid me a lot of money,
if the publisher hadn't gone
into involuntary liquidation
between the first print run selling out
and the second print run never happening
and before any royalties could be paid.
It would have done.
And I shrugged.
And I still had my electric typewriter.
And enough money to pay the
rent for a couple of months,
and I decided that I'd
do my best in future
not to write books just for the money.
If you didn't get the money
then you didn't have anything,
and if I did work I was proud of,
and I didn't get the money,
well, at least I'd have the work.
Every now and then, I forget that rule.
And whenever I do, the
universe kicks me hard
and reminds me.
I don't know that it's an
issue for anybody but me,
but it's true that nothing I did
where the only reason for
doing it was the money
was ever worth it, except
as bitter experience.
Usually I didn't wind up
getting the money, either.
(congregation laughs)
The things I did because I was excited,
and wanted to see them exist in reality,
have never let me down,
and I've never regretted
the time I spend on any of them.